- Back off, I'm benching Trubisky.
- Do you think he’s coming back?
- I don't know...
- I’m going to light it up.
OH SH—. OH NO. OH, OH MY BAD, EVERYONE.
- I won’t trade you, Master Trubisky. I can’t.
Because that would mean I messed up.
- [Mitchell Trubisky:] Not gonna lie: My confidence is pretty low right now.
Stay, uh...away from my team, Foles. Please.
- YOU MERELY ADOPTED CONTROVERSY! I WAS BORN IN IT.
- You know, once again, I found myself in a hole.
- Whole dang comic book world is going wacky out there.
- OK, which of us is starting Dolphin Man?
- And Washington to the playoffs! But without Haskins.
- NO! I RENOUNCE MY WISH!
- [Chanting voices:] MITCH. TRU. BIS. KY.  MITCH. TRU. BIS. KY.
- SEVEN-YARD SCREEN PASS.
I did it! I threw left!
- Come with me. You don’t owe these people anything.
- They do constantly bring up the whole Mahomes/Watson thing...
But we must fight, Catman.
- Man, you play for the Jags once, and that s--t follows you forever…
- Sorry to blow up your playoff chances. We want the BYEEE!
- I’m putting Mitch in now. I’m a good coach.
- Yo, we already blew it. You're good, bro.
- I’m gonna go bomb on the road.
- Because he’s not the hero Chicago deserves, but the one it needs right now.
Oh wait, no. Is it the other way around?
No. He’s the hero we don’t want but ha—
No, no. He’s the hero we deserve but shouldn’t extend.
No, no. He’s the hero we don’t want.
I’m the hero we deserve? I—